サッブ パパッス アカラナン クサラッス ウパ サンプラ サチッタ パリヨ ダパナン エタン ブッダナ サーサナン
はい これで俗世間的な話が終了しましたね
元の忘れかけていたウェーサーカ祭りに戻ります
で 皆様ご存知通りに お釈迦様の誕生
成道 初涅槃というつの出来事を祝う祭りになっています
ウェーサーカ祭は歴史的にいつ始めたかということは私は考えたことはないし
よくわからないような状態だと思います
これは私の個人的な考えですからね
決して相手にする必要はないんです
で 昔から仏教というのはね
日常生活のガイドラインとして使っていたものだから
そんなにお祭りとかのためには使わないんです
でお祭りと言ったっても
祭り気分でやるのはお寺を作ることやら
あるいは法話祭りなどは昔
歴史的にね 紀元一世紀あたりもちょっと前からもね
あったんですね で 法話祭りっていうのは
ある大事な経典を一つ選んで
これをものすごい優秀なお坊さん一人ぐらいは法話をする
で その場合はだいたい徹夜して説法するんです
ですから 徹夜してずっと喋るということはね
ちょっと難しいんだから
で 当時ではね 今の注釈書ではなくて
シンハラ民族が最初に作ったスリランカ国で膨大な注釈があったんですね
ですから 今は本当に省略バージョンで残っているのは
ですから それを学んだ有名なお坊さんたち方
王様も参加するし 朝まで説法はするんです
ですから いろいろそこに加えてお祭りなどはあったでしょうと思いますね
そういう経典もありましてね
経典 ちょっと内容は難しいんですね
で だから直々王様がいたんだから
王様のお祭りぐらいですね
あの人のお祭りの場合は
まあどうせスリランカの昔の王様たちというのはお寺育ちですから
もともと寺子なんですね
結局は ですから 自分のお祭りなのであろうとも
お坊さんも参加するというね
昔あったのは 田んぼの祭り
稲 田植え祭り 稲刈り祭り
稲刈りというんですかね
それから米を籾を取ってからね
脱穀して米にするんですね
そこは最初のと 米をお寺に差し上げるということがあって
これが派手な祭りなんです
かなり楽しく踊りやったり
いろんなパレードがあったりとかね
でやっていたんです だから
面白い祭りだったから
人間はどうせどんな国の人間もお祭りやりますよ
だいたい日本の祭りにしたっても
豊作の祭りなどなど それから無病息災のための祭りとかね
ものでしょうしね で 昔はね
病気にかかったらインフルワクチンということはなかったんだから
結局はワクチンの代わりにちょっと派手なお祭りやるんですよ
これで結構精神的にものすごく豊かになりますから
病気が消えてしまいますね
今はそのチャンスないんです
みんなガクーンと暗くなるでしょう
どん底 だからコロナさんがえらい元気なんです
昔はガクーンと落ち込むしないんです
派手な祭りやろうではないかと
人々はいろんな病気で死んでいくんだからね
これはあかんだと祭りやってわいわい騒いで楽しむんです
それでそのパワーでね
だいたい病気がなくなってきたんですね
同時に遺伝的にすごい抵抗のある人間も生まれてきたんですね
じゃあ今は科学時代ですからね
その考えは変わっているし
しかし 心の力っていうのは馬鹿にすることはできないんですね
昔はね まあ心の力って一番大事に考えていたんですね
物質の力をそんなに気にしなかったんですね
だけど 科学時代が来て
物質こそ神様ってことになっちゃって
唯物主義思考になっちゃって
政治学的ではなくて 科学者も唯物主義思考なんですね
それで心を無視したところで
結構みんな病気なんですね
物理的な病気を抑えているんだけど
それでも現代医療には人の病気を治す力は未だにないんです
未だに病気を治すのは
各個人の患者さんの精神力なんです
それで何か物質を入れてあげても
その物質は体を受け取って
体それに反応して 新しい細胞システムを作っていかないとどうにもならないんです
日本の先生方の一部はね
やっぱり治療は心でやるもんやと思っている先生方もいますよ
だから患者さんもすごく明るく元気で
明るく元気で変ですね
病気だからね すごい精神的に明るくて
笑顔でニコニコと笑っていた方がものすごい治療効果が早いという考えはある
日本の先生方はいらっしゃいます
ですから この 我々は仏教で言ってる
この明るい精神ね 貪瞋痴のない
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみのない心で生活しなさいと
それから思いやりのある
慈しみにあふれた心を持ちなさいよというのは
それが健康の秘密でもあります
長寿の秘密でもあります
豊かさの秘密でもあります
心清らかな人が畑 田んぼをやってもかなり豊作なんです
で 私はいろいろ調べたこともありますけど
その時でも虫は野菜食ったりしますよ
食ったりしても なんか虫さんもよく知って
自分たちがありがたくいただいているんだと
あれ 全部破壊しませんね
自分たちは 1本2本の木に
そこで生活して それを食べて
そちら大きくなって出ていくんですね
それはたくさん虫が出たからといって問題は起きません
なぜならば鳥たちも来て
これは召し上がるんだから
虫たちをね だから敵のない気持ちでね
活動してましたし だから化学的にからくりした肥料は使わなかったし
ですから この食食べるものを少量でみんな元気でしたんです
すごい元気でした そっちを食べたらもういいやということになるんです
体に必要なものは全部取り入れちゃいますから
今食べてもそこで体に悪い化学物質どうするの？ということで
体がすごく困るんです
ですから 今の状況は食べなかったら年取って衰えるし
食べたら早く衰れるという状態になっているんですね
だから最近はこのバイオティクのね
まあ有機栽培は謳ってますけども
まあ難しいですね 年を食わしてるんだからね
有機栽培のものっていうのは
もうものすごく美味しいし
たくさん食べなくてもいいんです
体全部それは栄養分は取ります
そういうことだから この昔のお祭りっていうのはそういうことで
一般人の日常のお祭りと仏教一緒になってお祭りをやっていたんですね
だから 昔のスリランカの国しか私はカエルと同じくね
外の世界を知らないだからね
祭りを見ると 何でも仏教の祭りなんです
例えば稲刈りはお祭りです
みんな村の人々集まって
まあお祭りやって三宝に帰依して
それで歌いながら稲刈りをする
歌は全部仏法僧の徳音になる歌なんです
それからハチャメチャ感謝する歌なんです
母親であろうか おじいさん
おばあ様であろうか 大地であろうか
天であろうか 雨であろうか
太陽であろうか どうでもいいんです
みんなにも感謝しまくる歌を歌いながら
稲刈りをする そこで脱穀するときは牛たちが脱穀するんだから
牛たちを褒め称えて歌うんです
牛たちも調子に乗るでしょうね
まあわからないです でも人間が牛さん
自分の子供のように思うおかげで
私と妻と子供たちが食べているんだから
本当にありがとうと っていうと
この気持ちが伝わりますね
牛をもうこれは歩くことじゃないんだからね
これ終わったらお前殺して食べてやるぞとかないんだからね
だからこの すごい楽しいんですよ
牛も仲間で ヤギも仲間で
みんな仲間で兄弟の感じで
だからどこを見ても仏教祭りになってますよ
仏教に関係ない祭りがありまして
スリランカの南部の方で
あれは何祭りっていうんですかね
鬼頭の祭りですけどね
悪霊払いって鬼頭祭りとか
あれは仏教文化でもないし
なんかどこから入ってきたかわからんだけど
おそらく遠い昔からのね
習慣かもしれませんだけど
鬼の仮面かぶっていろんなことを踊るんです
しかし 仏教が入ったら
それも鬼の仮面かぶって
もうわけもわからない神話物語使って踊ったりするんだけど
使う音楽 歌はすべて仏教になっているんですね
だからまず三宝に帰依して
三宝を讃嘆する歌をたくさん歌ってから
鬼を呼びおせるんです
そんな感じでね だからそういう仏教でない鬼と追い払いお払い祭りであっても
結局は仏教の祭りになったんで変わっちゃうんですね
だから当時 昔はあえてウェーサーカ祭りというお釈迦様だけのためにお祭りということはなかったんじゃないかなとは思いますね
ですから いつからこれ始めたのかっていうことがよく疑問なんです
そこであの年 12月 暦でね
月のあれ カレンダーだからね
ムーンカレンダーですからね
だから このそのその月でお釈迦様の歴史の中で起きた大きな出来事
例えば来週 来週満月ですからね
来週 本物のウェーサーカですよ
これを公園でどこかでやる計画でしたから
この日にちになっただけでね
それ中止になったら 本当のウェーサーカの日で行うこともできたし
あと来週とかね あれ ちょっと忘れちゃった
ですから この5月 次の
月ではなくて 次のマントウェーサーから33ヶ月目とね
で お釈迦様が初転法輪を唱えたお祭りで
そういうふうにいろいろありますよ
うん その場合は宗教的なことで
お寺でみんな八戒十戒を守って
お経を唱えて修行して帰るというふうになっていたんですね
おそらくこのウェーサーカ祭りみたいな特別な祭りになったのは
この植民地時代からではないかなと思います
で 自分の国を勝手に取り上げて
正しい宗教はキリスト教に限っているんだよと偉そうなことを言ったりすると
もう一般人でも腹が立ってしょうがないんですね
土地を奪っただけじゃなくて
文化も宗教も何から何までこいつら破壊するんだよと
だから派手動物を殺して
もう鶏は殺しまくっちゃって
他の殺しまくっちゃって
クリスマスやるでしょうにね
クリスマス何やといったら
まあイエスの誕生 ああ
そうか じゃあ俺たちはキリスト教じゃないんだから
ブッダの誕生をやろうではないかということで見たら
伝統的に誕生 成道 八正道は全部ウェーサーカで起きたんだから
じゃあウェーサーカ祭りにしようかなと言って
もうキリスト教の人々は縮むぐらいのおっかないぐらいの勝手に
ウェーサーカ祭りやることになっちゃったんです
どれほど迫力あってウェーサーカ祭りやるのかというと
あのキリスト教の人もそれに参加する羽目になっちゃったって
みんな教会であっても
お疲れ様 こちらにあるような提灯とかね
教会でも一つ二つ作ってぶら下がっておくんです
とにかく明かり明かりを差し上げるっていうことはね
特徴なんです みんなそれ考えてないことを忘れると面白いでしょうがないんです
だからこのヘーマラタさんも一生懸命提灯作りましたけど
スリランカから材料を取り寄せてもらったりとかね
私は何やってるのかといろいろ馬鹿にしてたんだけど
これは遺伝的にヒストリーがあるんで
それをわかってないんです
それっていうのは この初転法輪経でアーノーコードまで光が現れたと
それが大事なんです より光が現れたと
世は暗闇にいたんですね
ということは もう無明で無知で
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみでお互いに殺し合いやりながら
もう生きるは生きるは
何のために生きるのかわからないし
こういうもう畜生の動物と何の変わりもなく
それよりもひどいことをやったりしてね
互い殺しは動物やらんでしょうに
同じ種は互いに殺しませんよ
人間だけに だからインドの釈迦にせとってもね
生贄をやったり 神様の機嫌を取るために
そこで仏教の人々は だから殺される動物はヤギは怖くて泣いてるでしょう
かわいそうでしょう いいえ
神様のために命を差し上げるんだな
差し上げるから そのまま天国に行くんだよ
ヤギさん それで仏教の人の反応だったら
お前自分で生贄になった方が早いでしょうと
うん 話は本当ならん だから
そういう世界に光が現れたんです
お釈迦様が悟ったことで
それで科学者にはかなわない
みんなにもいまだにまだなかなか理解できないぐらいの
あの真理の世界 あの時代で解かれたんです
今のブッダの教えは最新なんです
私は これはちょっと汚すだけで
日本人の言葉を借りて
日本人の表現借りて 日本人の好み
好き嫌い 価値判断借りて
その器に入れているんですね
そうすると汚れるんです
しかし 理解するために
各人が持っている理解という理解能力という器に入れなきゃ理解できないんです
だから もっともっと時代が変わって
人々の 思考やらね 価値観が変わると
またアプローチを変えて仏教を語らなくちゃあかんです
そのために仏教は純粋に守らなくちゃあかんです
例えば 私の話だけ記録して経典捨てちゃっちゃうと終わりです
私の話はある時期まで通じるかも
それでなんか古臭い話だなとわかった途端
また経典を取ってきて読んでみなくちゃあかんです
そうすると その時代に適した教えが現れてくるんです
そういう 教えでしょ だから科学は光を照らしてないんです
地球以外生命がいるっていうことは
お釈迦様は何のことなく言っているんだからね
今も科学者はまあ可能性大いにあり
それだけなんです 仏教はな
何のことなく これこれぐらいの宇宙はブッダの力が入る範囲やとかね
もっとありますよとかね
一般的に語ることでしたからね
はい そういうことで明かり
光が現れた ターロクドパーリ
だからウェーサーカ祭りは光の祭りになっちゃったんです
光が現れたよと だから昔時代
昔っていうのは電気電力来る前の時代でね
夜は暗いだからね みんな自分の家の中にいるんだからね
ウェーサーカ祭りになってくると
朝まで明かりがどこでも外にあるんです
だからすごくあえてハイライトはされます
そういうことで これは智慧の光が現れたという祭りでもあります
解脱の扉が開きましたというね
お祭りもあります 結局楽しい祭りなんです
そんなすごい怯えて震えてやるものじゃないんです
はい まあウェーサーカ祭りのことで
そんな程度のことだとは思いますけど
このキリスト教のクリスマスの影響だなとも
もう一つ証拠なんですけど
あのグリーティングカードありますね
あの 日本では年賀状ありますね
大体ヨーロッパ文化ではクリスマスカードなんですね
みんなにカード送るんですね
その中で新年も入れておくんですね
スリランカではグリーティングカードは送りません
その代わりにウェーサーカの日でみんな片っ端からグリーティングカードを送るんです
祝福して だからそれは当然西洋の真似でしょ
だから結構いろんな種類の
ものすごいたくさん 今はどうか分からないけど
あの今は政治家がブッダだと思ってる時代だからね
どうか分からんだけど
我々の子供の頃はね もう店に行ったら大量にあるはあるわ
グリーティングカードですね
そうすると我々はお兄ちゃんにこれ
お母さんにこれとかね
で選ぶんですよ あ おじいちゃんにはこれとかね
それぞれこの親戚関係に買えて買わでカードあるんです
ですから 大体この現代
我々やっている祭りっていうのは
まあそういう風な現れたものだなとは思います
あのもう遠い昔からあった習慣ではないんです
それでも結構歴史ありますけどね
イギリス植民地になったのは１８１８ １９
年でしたからね か１６ １７
よく覚えてないんだけど
それでやさ長老の提案がありまして
何かお経の人を説明しなくちゃなんだからね
アネーキジャティ サンサーランということを説法したらどうですかと
私はこれは何回も繰り返しちゃったんだけど
リピートはしたくないとものすごい反対しましたが
もうかえって他の提案も出てこないしね
私も別に経典を選ぶのは面倒くさいっていう感じでね
で この我々は大体伝統的にこの十二因縁唱えたら
次必ずアネーキジャティ サンサーランというダンマパダの偈を唱えるんですね
だから唱える文化ではもうこれセットなんですね
それカットして唱えることはしません
お釈迦様がね 悟ってから
世の中の現象ってどういう風になっているのかということは
もう喋らなくちゃなんだからね
人間に喋るためにいろいろ目的概念を当てはめて考えて
世に初めてこの因縁法則というね
パティッチャ サムッパダーダというね
ものは存在しないんだよと
条件的で一時的に現れるものだけだと思ったら
これは誰にもわからないんだと
みんなものはあると思っているんだよと
大変なことになっちゃったんです
これを教えるよりは黙った方が楽ではないかなと思うところまでお釈迦様がびっくりしたんですね
難しさに それでも自分一人
それ悟ったんだから その喜びをウダーナとして唱えたんです
だからダンマパダだけではなくて
そのアネーキジャティ サンサーランというのはウダーナにもあります
だからお釈迦様の最初の喜びの言葉というね
悟った時の喜びの言葉ということで
読んでみます 解説してみます
アネーカ ジャーティ サンサーラン サンダー ヴィッサン アニッビサン
アネーカ ジャーティっていうのは
無数の妖怪は輪廻ですね
生まれるは生まれるは死ぬは
まだどこかで流れが現れるは
私が死んで生まれることではなくて
私がっていうのはこの世の中だけのことでしょ
一時的 言葉でしょ ではなくて
エネルギーはエネルギーですから
また現れ また新しい私がそこで現れちゃって
そこでハチャメチャなことをして生きていて
また老いて死んじゃって
また別なところで私が現れて
また俺こそ世界一やと思って
またバカなことをやって生きていて
このキリがないんですね
今も我々は人生に疲れているのに
このプログラムはまたリピートしなさい
またリピートしなさいと
やってもやってもはい
リピート はい リピート
はい やり直し はい やり直し
永久的にやり直し やり直しで気持ちいいんですかね
あ できたぞと言われてほしいでしょう
だからこれはパソコン用語で言えば
このパソコンにあるプログラムを組んで
使っている人に あなたはこういうこういうものに応えて
こういう風ななんか作文でも何でもインプットしてくださいと
で パソコン様が評価してあげますと
そうすると我々はプログラムを組む人が
このプログラムコマンドにインプット入ったら
次のコマンドはやり直しってコマンドを入れとくんです
やり直しでループをまた元のインプット状態に持っていく
そうすると この人はいくらデータインプットして
いくら作品作文書いて入れても
完了ボタンを押した途端やり直し
再びまたページが出てくる
名前から生年月日から全部入れてくださいと
腹が立つでしょう この銀行関係に時々私にも起こりますけど
このあの遅いんだから
私はね あの時間経過したんだから元に戻りますと
それでまたもう一度アクセスして
もう一度パスワードを入れて
もう一度 もうもういやになっちゃうんです
その場合でも ちゃんと早いスピードでデータ入れれば
銀行のプログラムは OK になりますけど
もし人生のパソコンプログラム
そうじゃないんです いくら生まれてからずっと頑張って年取って老いて
もう孫の顔を見て 子供に孫に財産も分配してあげて
死んじゃっても はい やり直しと
やってないような感じ
何にも それでまた再びそういう苦しいプログラムね
闘いながらもいろんなことやって
やっと生きていて 年取って死んじゃったらはい
やり直しってなるとクタクタ疲れるでしょうに
面白いこと誰も疲れてないね
お釈迦様だけですね これ
輪廻転生って疲れるんだよ
なんだこりゃと だから理性のある人はパソコン蹴っ飛ばしちゃえばいいでしょ
この野郎 俺はインプットしないよと
だって意味がないんだから
インプットしたらはい
やり直し だったらそれいらんでしょうに
それは一般の人にはわからないんです
だからお釈迦様に光が現れたんです
あ これ蹴ったぶすものだと
データインプットするものじゃないんだと
蹴っ飛ばしてぶん殴るものであると
だから我々は偉そうに仏教にも悪口言いながら
お釈迦様にも悪口言いながら何やってます？データインプットしているんです
朝ごはん作るのは 晩ご飯作るのは
それから昼ご飯を作る
順番間違えちゃったね
そういうことをやって買い物をするは
服を洗濯するは 掃除を掃除
掃除をするは 明日また朝ごはん作ろうか
掃除かけるとかね データインプットしているんです
それでできなくなったら坊主に現れて死んじゃうし
それからまたどこかで自分の業によってやり直しと
そこで牛になったら牛のプログラムでデータインプットする
ミミズになったらミミズのプログラムでデータインプットする
神になったら神のプログラムでデータインプットする
例えば死んで神になったっても
はい インプットしてくださいと
いつだってまたデータインプットするんです
で 紙としてのプログラム通りに生きているんです
それで寿命が終わったら死んじゃう
またデータインプットしてくださいと
それは輪廻転生なんです
だから他宗教と一般人が来世を生まれるために
頑張っているんです バカみたいです
なぜならば これインプットしたら
次もう一回インプットすることを期待しているんです
あんまりにも馬鹿馬鹿しい
これアンケートたくさんデータあるとしましょう
もう例えばもう ８２３項目あるとしましょうか １
終わったらはい １終わって２
はい ２  ８２３個終わったらはい
全部完了 はい 送信してくださいと
そうしたらまあまあはい
ありがとうございます
再び１からインプットしてください
また ８２３項目 で 宗教の話聞いちゃうと
死んでから天国に行くこと
どこかにくだらんところに行くことを考えているんです
仏教文化になってくると
また新しい天国を作るんですね
極楽どうやらもう大日如来のなんとか地獄やらね
そういういろいろものを作って
そちらに行きたいんだと
まああるならば行ってもいいんだけど
なかったら最悪ですね
極楽道なんかなかったら
だって お釈迦様はおっしゃってないし
それから人々が考えて作ったものだから
それもね ふざけて考えているよりは
仏教の大事な方々はすごい超エリートでしたから
みんなすごくそれなりに哲学的に考えて
穴があって その穴に何か概念入れちゃうんですね
大日如来っていうのは
私は宗教的には馬鹿にするんだけど
哲学的にはあの大日如来といった単語を作ったところは大失敗で
宇宙法則のことなんです
宇宙法則は仏教になってくると物質法則でも心の法則なんですね
だから２つ合わせているんです
だからこの法則システムをがあるんだと
お釈迦様はそれを４つに分けているんです
昨日の説法で見ましたからね
宇宙法則という１個ってして
本当は４つあるんです
法則は この４つでぐるぐるぐるぐる全部回っているんで
それをわからない馬鹿には
それは大日如来という如来様よと言っちゃえば
ああ ありがたい ありがたいというところじゃないんです
ありがたくないんです
だって繰り返すプログラムインプットしなくちゃいけないんだから
だからお釈迦様がその大日如来っていうからくりが４つだよと
それを理解しなさいと
あの４つ言ってもまあ忘れるでしょ
今日スライドとか何もないんだからね
まあカンマニアはビージュニアはチッタニアはウトゥニヤマというフォープリンシプルシステムですね
カンマニアというのは業の法則
業っていうエネルギーがあって
自分勝手な法則で働く
チッタニヤマは心という法則が
心があるではなくて 法則があるんです
法則によって それ地球の自転と同じです
これ法則です 誰かがこれ蹴っ飛ばして回っているわけじゃないんです
法則によって回っているんです
だから止まらないんです
法則だから だから我々も宇宙スペースで
私は喋っている間で おそらくまあ百万キロぐらいもう動いているんです
元いた場所じゃない 今は
太陽でもこの惑星たちを持ってガーってスピードで動いています
ですから それは誰にも止まることもできないし
誰かがやっているわけでもないんで
法則です チッタニヤマ
ビジャニヤマっていうのは
この遺伝子と同じ法則なんです
コピーして同じパターンを作るというね
前のものから一つコピーして
それ壊れるとまたもう一つコピー作ってやるという
現代の人々には微妙にちっちゃいことしか理解できないんだから
遺伝子はどうなるの？遺伝子でしょ
我々の場合は 最初に １個の細胞で遺伝子が出来上がっちゃうと
その遺伝子がずっと死ぬまでそのプログラムでやるんで
それを種の法則というんですね
遺伝子に限ったものじゃないんです
心働く場合もコピー機能働くんです
前と同じものを今考えるんです
料理を作る時でもコピーするんです
前と同じ でも前と似ている
同じじゃないんです 決して同じものを作れないんです
それみんな誤解するところで
だからコピーマシンで原稿をコピーしたからって同じものじゃないんです
全く違うものでしょうか？と言ったら困りますね
それでも コピーでしょと言った方がいいんです
だから我々は仕事をする時でも
喋る時でも 考える時でも
ちょっとコピー機能を使っているんです
だからちょっと喋ったら
えっ もう一度言ってください
ちょっとえ？ってことになるんです
それでリピートするんだけど
コピーです 前と同じじゃないんです
原稿を読み上げて ちょっと発音間違ったんだからもう一度読み上げてくださいって言ったら
それは間違ったところ直すって言えますけど
2回目違うんですね 残念ですけど
原稿を読み上げても  2回目読み上げると違うんです
そういう風にビジャニヤマの種の法則
次はリトミヤマと言ってね
宇宙の 自説って通告書にも書いてますけどね
あの自説単語を使ってるのは人間にわかるためにね
これ人間にわからないんだから
本当は自説って意味じゃないんです
事っていうのは 宇宙を見たらそちらの自説もありますよ
例えば一つ太陽 1個見たら
同じ力で燃えているわけじゃないんです
いろいろ起きますよ 爆発したり
ものすごく猛烈に燃えたり
またゆっくり燃えたり
いろいろ最後にあまりにも派手に燃えちゃうんですね
その場合は もし周りに生命がある惑星なんかいたら
あいつらもうみんな死んじゃいますよ
放射線で そこで爆発して死ぬか
そのまま死ぬか いろいろ死に方あるんですね
だからそういうことっていうのは
そちらのパターンがあるんですね
惑星には惑星のパターンがあって
太陽には太陽のパターンがあって
星団には星団の天の川に天の川のパターンがあるんですね
そういう風にこの我々人間から見れば自説
夏と冬は結構違うんですね
夏の考え方と冬の考え方
我々人間であっても変わるんです
別児になるんです だけど
木下さんがいるんだから名前借りますけど
夏の木下さんと冬の木下さんは同じじゃないんです
自説によって変わるんです
はい そういう法則ですね
第二の狙いになっちゃったのは
だから我々は法則上説法するんだから
第二に 狙いの話は木下さんが持ってくると
何かあれが立って喧嘩するんです
本当に喧嘩くだらんですよ
別にどうったことはないんです
それは意味がないんだよ
もう本当の意味に入ってみたら
喧嘩することは何もないんです
おっかない法則です それだけ
では おかもとんでもないこと
壊せと 蹴っ飛ばせ だってこのアルゴリズムはいつでも確実にもうループ作ってね
元に戻ってデータインプットラインに来るんだから
そこである人がパソコン向かって１０年もデータインプットし続けたならば
いつか OK おめでとうございます
出るだろうと思って その馬鹿がの裏のアルゴリズムライン読んでないんです
今はほとんどのプログラムロックしていますから
昔 私はパソコン即時時代ではプログラムコードにアクセスできるんです
だから私も時々気に入らないだったらちょこちょこっと変えたりするんです
そうすると 自分の希望通りのプログラムが動いたりするんですね
例えば３回でゲーム終わりになるというラインになったら １０
それ１０にするんです
じゃあ邪魔見ろと 今はできませんよ
全部ガチンとロックしてコードはオープンできないんですね
だからまあまあ余計な話なんか知ったかぶりというような感じもします
しますしね  ある人がもうずっと１０年もかけてデータインプットし続けたならば
その人に何か問題ありますね
活塞があるんです 何回もこれ打って打って
データインプットして終わっちゃうと
必ずおめでとうございます
あなたは大成功と言ってくれるんだよという
だから我々もとんでもない馬鹿だから
生きてみたら何か必ずすごいご褒美が落ちてくるだろうと
大黒さんの持ってるなんとかありますね
あれが降って降りてくると思ってるんです
だから人間が仏教は大嫌いで
データインプット作業に入っているんです
それは１行でお釈迦様おっしゃってます
アネーガジャーディサンサーラ
無数の生まれでサンダービッサンアニッビッサン
何でしたっけ？あの読み上げて当てどなく
やり やりまくっちゃったよと
回転しましたよと アニッビッサン
もう嫌や もうやるわ やるわ
いくらやっても終わりじゃなかったということね
そこでガハカーラカン
ガヴェーサンとドゥッカジャーティプナ
ですから お釈迦様はこのプログラムを作る人を探していたんですね
先生 ちょっとちょっと問題があるんじゃない？と言いたくて
家を作る人 家っていうのは命のことです
これ文学だから これウダーナですからね
どうしても文学作品です
ですから そういう言葉を使うんです
家を作る人を探していたんだと
なぜならば 再び生まれること
苦しいからですと これは苦しいじゃと
データインプットしても
また再びインプットしてくださいと出てくる
もう嫌になっているんです
なんだこりゃと はい ガハカーラギトス見つけたよと
プログラマープログラマーを見つけましたよ
命を作る作るやつは見つけましたよと
プナゲーハンラカもう二度とこれはまたやれました
できません 例えばエンコーディングリストもらっちゃったら
あれ ループの１行取る取り出すだけでしょ
イッナニナニでンナニナニというプログラムありますね
それは抜けるんです そこで私が言った同じことで
サッバーテーパーツカバッガ
日本訳はなんでしたっけ？アンジーパーリはことごとく俺まあ壊しちゃったんです
だから蹴っ飛ばして壊しちゃったんです
パソコンの ガハクータンウィサンキタン
そこでプログラムいわゆる組み立てる
この元になったところ
何か元になって そこからいろいろなサブプログラムを組んだからね
それも壊しましたよと
それからヴィサンカーラガタンチッタン
まあ心には何もサンカーラが衝動がなくなったと
いわゆる心の中で全ての概念
観念 感情 あらゆるものを綺麗に綺麗に消えてしまったと
タンナーナンカヤマッジカ渇愛をなくしたと
だから輪廻転生するのはこの渇愛のせいなんです
なんかあると思っちゃうんです
だから生きることは苦だから渇愛が生まれるんです
食べるものは塩が足らなかったらどうなる？渇愛が生まれるんです
ちょっと塩を振りましょうと
いつでも渇愛が現れるんです
そういうことで 渇愛に駆られ
人々は輪廻転生するんだよという
お釈迦様のすごい言葉なんで
これは 命を作る人を探しましたと
だから他宗教でも命を作る人は神様と思っていたんだけどね
お釈迦様は探していたんです
神様を見つけたら 外にいるんじゃなくて
自分の心にいるんですね
命を作るやつが 渇愛というものが踏みつけたんです
ガハクーダというのは
ガハクーダ 日本語で何でしたっけ？ 屋根
屋根 でも梁をつなげる部品なんで
ガハクーダっていうのは
屋根でもないんですけどね
昔の建物なんか上なんかちょっと出っ張ったものがあって
全部大きい梁が好きなつなげておくんです
それ壊しちゃった だからこれを大きい木を持ってきたっても
つなげるとこはないんですね
ガハクーダというのは無明のことですね
屋根っていうのは だから
暗闇でいて みんな言う通りに勉強して
ご飯食べて運動して 結婚して子孫を作って死ねば
それこそ正しいやって
無知ですから その道はね
だからそれではなくて
良い道を ですね だからそれで全部法則壊しちゃったんです
はい それで個人個人でもその経験はできるし
自分の渇愛がなくなったとよくわかりますよ
心に妄想は思考はあれやこれや悩む
なくなっちゃうと衝動がなくなるとすごい楽ちんです
ものすごく楽ちんです
皆さんはあれやらなくちゃ
これやらなくちゃってことで生きてるでしょ？結構ストレスです
それは すごいストレスです
やらなくてはことができなかったらどう？結構ひどい目に遭うでしょ
自分自身で自分の思考で
ちょっとイメージしてください
やらなくてはというあの一つの概念消えたらどうですかね
どれほど楽かと やらなくてはという強迫観念がなくてもできるでしょうに
その場でその場で必要なことはできる
ああ やらなくてはとか
それだけ消したことをイメージできるでしょうに
どれほど気分爽快になるのかと
どれほど笑えるのかとわかると思います
はい そういうことで お釈迦様の最初のウダーナは悟ってから唱えたもので
悟ってから ２週間目  3週間目かその辺ですね
4週間目かそこら辺で唱えた時で
すごい面白いことをおっしゃっているんです
現代的なパソコン用語に入れ替えてみると
壊せということだよ プログラム削除しなさい
めんどくさくないやと
瞬間でできるでしょうに
プログラムのアイコンを取ってゴミ箱に引っ越しするだけ
いたって簡単に それで終わり
そういう感じでお釈迦様が皆様に簡単に涅槃の道を教えたんです
はい 話は以上です そういうことで
昨日のサヤもサヤドはね
英訳で唱えたんですけど
ざっくりわからなかったんだけど
初転法輪経とアナッラッカナ経典ですね
だいたい兄弟経典ですね
五人比丘たちに初転法輪経と教えてから
プライベートレッスンを教えて
それからみんなまとめて最後の卒業授業をやったんですね
卒業授業はアナッラッカナスッタなんですね
我々には省略バージョンしか残ってないんだけどね
1日2日半かけてアナッラッカナ経典を唱えた
お釈迦様教えたんだから
かなり詳しく教えたでしょうね
だから これはミャンマー仏教でもすごい尊い
ありがたいとは思っているし
だからサヤドウなんか感じたでしょうね
教会は大変危険な状態になっていて
ということはね だからいろいろご利益のダラニパーリッタどうかはみんなに教えたんだけど
あれは私に紹介できないんです
パーリ語のライン教えたら
これ日本語訳では何の意味もないんです
で 力も入らないと パーリ語のバージョンの私はもう
私はもともとそういう世界性格じゃないんだからね
笑って置いといたんですけど
私のいくつかのそういう呪文っぽいものを教えてくれたことあるんで
トラブってる時 あのね
まあこれこれ唱えてくださいと
なんかわからないんだけど
こちら私はタルボはよくハードは知ってるんです
さっさと来てこれこれやりなさいって言うんです
ですから このあれはちゃんと唱えて欲しかったんですが
まあ今度会った時か どなたでも会った時
そこをパーリの文字でダラニパーリッタというね
ダラニ自体は大乗仏教の単語ですけどね
で まあ教えてもらったら皆さん紹介することができます
それで私が考えたのは
この私と平松さんで最後に諸天法輪経を正名で唱えましょうということです
それから終了いたします
サマンタチャックワレスアトラガッチャンとデーヴァタ
サッダムマンムニラージャススナンとサッガムックダン
ダンマサワンカールアヤンバダンタ
パリッタダンマサワンカールアヤンバダンタ
ナモタスバガトゥ アレーアトゥサンマサンブッダッス
エワンメシタンエカンサマヤンバガラー
マシアムヴィハーティイシパタネミグダーイ
タントリクバガヴァーパンチランギエビククアマンテーシー
メディックヴェアンターパンドジテーナセーヴィタブラー
ヨチャーヤンカーメスカーマスカリカーヌヨーゴー
ヒーノーガンモーポトゥンジャニコー
アナリヨアナッタサンヒトー
ヨチャーヤンアッテキレマターヌヨーゴー
ドゥッコアナリヨアナッタサンヒトー
エテーテーウボアンテーアヌパガッマ
マッジマパティパダータターガテーネアビサンブッダ
チャンコカーニニャーネカーニ
ウパサマーヤアヴィンヤーヤサンボーダー
バーナーヤサンワティターティ
カタマーチサービッカルマッジマ
パティパダータターガテーネアビサンブッダ
シャンクカーニーニャーナカーニーウパサマー
バーナーヤ サンワッタティ
アーヤメーワ アリーヨ アッタンギコマンゴー
セーイアティーダ  サッマディッティ サッマサンカンポ サッマワーチャ サッマカルマントー
サッマージーヴォ サッマヴァーヤーモ サッマサティ サッマサマーディ
イダンコ サ ビックウェ マッジマ パティパダー
タタガテーナ アビサン ブッダ
シャングカルニ ニャーナカルニ ウパサマーヤ アヴィンニャーヤ サンボーダーヤ
ニッバーナーヤ サンワッタティ
イダンコ パナ ビックウェ ドゥッカ アリーヤ サッチャー
ヤーティピ ドゥッカ ジャラーピ ドゥッカ ヴォヤーディピ ドゥッコ マラナンピ ドゥッカム
アンピーエーヒ サンパーヨゴ ドゥッコ ピエーヒ ヴィンパーヨゴ ドゥッコ
ヤンティンチャーナ ラパティカンティ ドゥッカム
サンキッテーナ パンチュパーダナッ カンダ ドゥッカ
イダンコ パナ ビックウェ ドゥッカ サムオダヤン アリーヤ サッチャー
ヤーヤン タンハー プノーバウィカ ナンディラーガサーガター
タトラ タトラー ビナンディーニ
セーイアティーダ  カーマタンハー バータンハー ヴィバータンハー
イダンコ パナ ビックウェ ドゥッカ ニローダン アリーヤ サッチャー
ヨータッサエーワ タンハーヤ アセーサヴィラーガ ニロードチャーゴ パティニッサーッゴ ムンティ アナーラヨ
イダンコパナ ビンカウェー ドゥッカニローダガ ミニパティパダー アリーヤ サッチャン
アイメーヴ アリーヨ アンタンギコ マッゴ
セーヤー キガン  サッマディッティ サッマ サンカッポ サッマ ワチャ サッマ カッマントゥ
サッマ ジーヴォ サッマ ヴァヤーモ サッマ サティ サッマ サマターディ
イダン ドゥッカング アリーヤ サッチャーンテ メー ビッカリ
ウンベ アナヌッステス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
ニャーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ アローコ ウデパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカング アリーヤ サッチャン パリンニャン テメー ビッカリ
ウンベ アナヌッステス ダメー ス チャックン ウデパーディ
ニャーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ アローコ ウデパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカング アリーヤ サッチャン パリンニャタン ティメー ビッカリ
ウンベ アナヌッステス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
ニャーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ アローコ ウデパーディ
イダン ドゥッカ サムダヤン アリーヤ サッチャンテ メー ビッカリ
トゥンベ アナヌッステス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
ニャーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ アローコ ウデパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ サムダヤン アリーヤ サッチャン
ワハ タッバン ティメー ビッカリ
ウンベ アナヌッステス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
ニャーナン ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ アローコ ウデパーディ
タンコパニダン ドゥッカ サムダヤン アリーヤ サッチャン
パヒナン ティメー ビッカリ
ウンベ アナヌッステス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
ニャーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ アローコ ウデパーディ
イダン ドゥッカ ニロダン アリーヤ サッチャンテ メー...
...ウンベ アナヌッス テス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
アーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ オーローコー ウデパーディア
サンコーパニダン ドゥッカニローダン アリーヤ サッチャー サッチカタ ブアンティメー ビックヴェ
ウンベ アナヌッス テス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
アーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ オーローコー ウデパーディ
サンコーパニダン ドゥッカニローダン アリーヤ サッチャー サッチカタン タメー ビッカー
ウンベ アナヌッス テス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
アーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ オーローコー ウデパーディ
サンコーパニダン ドゥッカニローダ ガーミニ パティパダーリーヤ サッチャー ティメー ビックヴェ
ウンベ アナヌッス テス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
アーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ オーローコー ウデパーディ
サンコーパニダン ドゥッカニローダ ガーミニ パティパダーリーヤ サッチャー バーヴェタン バンティメー ビッカーヴェ
ウンベ アナヌッス テス ダンメス チャックン ウデパーディ
アーナン ウデパーディ パンニャー ウデパーディ ヴィンニャー ウデパーディ オーローコー ウデパーディ
サンコーパニダン ドゥッカニローダ ガーミニ...パティパーラーリーサッチャー
バーリターンティメー
ビッカリ  ブッバーナンサテスダンメス
チャンカンウデパーディア
アーナンウデパーディ
パンニャーウデパーディ
ヴィッニャーウデパーディ
アーローコーウデパーディ
ヤーティワンチャメー
ビッカリ  イメーソチャトゥスーワリーヤサッチェスー
デーヴァーンティパリワッターン
ダーダサーカーラン ヤターブータンニャーナダッサーナー
ナスーヴィスーッダンアーホーシ
ネータワーン ビッカリ
サデーヴァケーローケー
サマーラケーサブラフマケー
サッサマナーブラフマニアパジャーヤ
サデーヴァマヌッサーヤ
アヌッタラーンサンマーサンボーディン
アビサンボッドーパンチャンニャーセ
ヤトーチャコーメー ビッカリ
イメーソジャトースーワリーヤサッチャーソー
デーヴァーンティパリワッターン
ダーダサーカーラン ヤターブータンニャーナダッサーナ
スースーダンナーセ  アッターン
ビッカリ サデーヴァケーローケー
サマーラケーサブラフマケー
サッサマナーブラフマニアパジャーヤ
サデーヴァマヌッサーヤ
アヌッタラーンサンマーサンボーディン
アビサンボッドーパンチャンニャーセ
アーナンチャパンメー
ダッサーナンウデパーディ
アコッパメーチェトー
ヴィモーティ アヤマンティマージャーテ
ナッティダーニプナンバウォター
イダマウォーチャバグヴァー
アッタマナーパンチャワッギア
ビックバガトー バーシタンアビナンダンター
デーヴァスミンチャパンウェーヤー
カルナスミンバンニャマーネー
アースマトーコンダンニャッサ
ヴィラジャンヴィータマランダンマチャンコン
ウデパーンダ  アンキンチサムウデヤダンマン
サッバンタンニロージャダンマンティー
バータタチャパンバガヴァター
ダンマチャンケー ブッマデーヴァー
サントマヌッサーヴェーソー
エタンバガヴァターバーラーナシヤン
イシパタネミグダーエー
アヌッタラーンダンマチャンカンパーヴァッティター
アンパティヴァッティアン
サマネーナヴァ ブラフマネーナヴァ
デーヴェーナヴァ マーレーナヴァ
ブラフマナーヴァーケーナチヴァ
ローカスミンティー  ブッマナンデーヴァーナ
サッダンソー......マーラージカーデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェッスー
エーターバガターバーラーナシヤン
イシパタネミガダーイェ
アヌッタランダンナチャッカンパワッキターン
オンプティヴァッティヤン
サマネーナヴァー バーヒマネー
バーワナヴァー マーレーナヴァー
ブラクマナヴァー ケーナチワーローカッスミントゥ
シャートゥマーラージカーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
ターヴァティンサーデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェーサー
ターヴァティンサーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
ヤマデーヴァー サッデマヌッサーヴェッスー
ヤマナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
トゥシターデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェーサー
トゥシターナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
ニムマナラティーデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェッスー
ニムマナラティーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
パラニムミテヴァサヴァッティーナデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェーサー
パラニムミテヴァサヴァッティーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
ブラフマパーリサッジャーデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェッスー
ブラフマパーリサッジャーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
ブラフマプローイターデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェッスー
ブラフマプローイターナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
マハーブラフマーデーヴァー
サッデマヌッサーヴェッスー
マハーブラフマーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
パリッターバーデーヴァー
サッダマヌッサーヴェッスー
パリッターバーナンデーヴァーナンサッダンシュンワー
アッパマーナバーデーヴァー
サッ...
サンバタリワンジャンタサンバルワガウィナッサトゥマテーラワッタントラーヤ スケーディガーユコバガヴァトゥ サッバマンガ
ラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァタ サッバグンヌーヌーバーウェーナ サダ サッティバワンタテー ヴァトゥ サッバマンガラ
ン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァタ サッバダンマヌーバーウェーナ サダ サッティバワンタテー ヴァトゥ サッバマンガラ
ン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァタ サッバサンガーヌーバーウェーナ サダ サッティバワンタテーナ カッタヤッ
カ ブータナン パパンガニバーラナ パリッタッサーヌーバーウェーナ アンタテー サワパンダ
アッカサッダチ ブンモッタ デーヴァナーガ マヒンディカ プンニャンタン アヌモーディットワ チラン ラッカントゥ
ローカサーサナン アッカサッダチ ブンモッタ デーヴァナーガ マヒンディカ プンニャンタン アヌモーデ
ィットワ チラン ラッカントゥ デーサナン アッカサッダチ ブンモッタ デーヴァナーガ マヒンディカ プンニャンタン
アヌモーディットワ チラン ラッカントゥ トン サダー
デーヴォヴァッサドゥカーレーナ サッササンパッティ ホートゥ チャ ヴィートー バワトゥ ローコー チャ ラージャー バワトゥ ダンミコー
イダン メー プンニャン アセヴァッカヤー ワハン オットゥ
ありがとうございました
カンティー パラマン タポーティティッカー ニッバーナン パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ